oh L Lord these are tears get emal I'm
like you're back you came back cuz you
came to talk about you're incredibly
interesting like I had not seen
something like it your show woke and you
know everybody loves you from New Girl
and now here you are in
Faro thank
you oh thank you thank you yeah Fargo is
a uh it's a departure from New Girl for
sure but so was woke I mean you're
really amazing at your range in fact
that plays right into the fact that you
also um were on one of my favorite shows
Drunk History yes and it is Martin
Luther King Jr day and you played Martin
Luther King Jr on Drunk History I did
looks just like
it um okay what is the most surprising
thing to you about being the parent of
Lily who's three I got to say she's
she's silly she's really funny and I I
didn't know you I'm silly I'm funny her
mom's an actor you know when I was
growing up I had a a lady at church um
my mom used to always like squeeze my
finger if I was acting up at church and
I would mock the preacher and I would
imitate the preacher so my mom would
always go stop stop and one day sister P
looked at my mom and said Gwen stop you
were the same way when you were a kid
and I was like oh
this whole time it's been a lie so I now
have permission and so with my daughter
when I see her acting up or or being
weird I you know part of me wants to go
hey knock it off but the other part is
like this is hilarious you know what I
mean like I should I should encourage
this Behavior okay um you apparently you
got some bad advice from Fargo like
co-stars what is that about well let me
just start by saying uh people can be
stupid just let me just say that okay so
we're in Calgary shooting in the middle
of the winter oh and um and some friends
they they decided to tell me hey you
know what's really good for you you got
to get in the hot tub and then get right
out then get into the cold plunge and
you know some people have a some people
say that it works scientifically they
can see you nodding saying it
works I got the worst cold of my life
after that I I go to I'm at I had to
cancel work I couldn't go to work for a
day you know what I mean because I got
so sick so I started this story by
saying people are stupid and I and in in
case of some of my co-stars from Fargo
that is true right they they LED you
down the wrong path yeah um okay Fargo's
set in Minnesota and actually in honor
of Minneapolis um we wanted to do a
little quick um yay or nay to our
friends in
Minneapolis um take a look what's up
guys it's Alexa Jordan from The CW Twin
City and next up we have the Juicy Lucy
yes it's a burger but not just any
Burger I'm talking cheese on the inside
cheese on the outside yay or
nay hi
guys are you kidding
me well hello to our like television
family over in Minnesota thank you for
letting us taste a Juicy Lucy which I
happen to actually really love ooh let's
see how this vibes with you say sorry to
my trainer